Hey, I'm Sara from Los Angeles.
I love kittens.
It's my biggest aspiration to have a kiddie pool full of kittens.
I recently moved here from Austin, Texas.
I was born and raised there so it's time to get out.
I've always done hair.
I cut people's hair in high school...
...and then right out of high school I went to beauty school.
It was great.
I kept getting kicked out of beauty school for various reasons.
One of them would be because I started working for a corporation...
...when I was still in school.
They didn't really care too much for not being able to say that they taught me my craft.
And when I graduated,...
...I was one of the few that I've ever known that graduated with a full portfolio.
I'm trying to get back in the swing of it,...
...but I've been really busy with modeling and running a lot to castings and stuff like that.
I love change 'cause if I sit still too long I start to go crazy.